[Musique]
la villa du département se prépare aux
festivités du nouvel an tamoul au rythme
de la musique et des percussions les
officiels assiste aux cérémonies
[Musique]
ils reçoivent le mahal et un collier de
fleurs traditionnelles inde où les
tambours résonnent et le jacquot entame
sa note
la réunion était construite à partir de
nos origines diverses et variées et
aujourd'hui il convient de célébrer
l'unité réunionnaise
à travers cette diversité nouvel an
tamoul est l'occasion pour nous et bien
sûr de montrer la culture est amoureux
sous tous ses aspects culinaires
gastronomique musicale surtout c'est
haro si on avait des musiciens de la
musique et de la danse
et c'est ça qui m'importe c'est de
montrer aux nouvelles générations que la
réunion s'est construite à partir de cet
hiver rapport des ateliers découverte de
la culture indienne sont proposés aux
visiteurs comme ici avec le unis
seulement les nuances en fait c'est une
feuille on écrase et que après on
applique maintenant ça se vend dans les
tubes en soit les feuilles crasé soit en
essence c'est pour la décoration des
mains avant les gens avait pas beaucoup
de bijoux alors dans ce décor et les
mains avec l'aîné et c'est un tatouage
qui est pas permanent qui peut enlever
les ordures
c'est ça représente la fête on applique
dans les mains souvent c'est quand il ya
des mariages tout ça on a préféré aux
commandes de sa peau il faut connaître
un petit peu de dessins et puis après
s'appliquer au cours de la soirée cinq
membres de la communauté tamoule
représentants d'associations ou poussard
y recevront pour leur engagement la
médaille départementale du mérite
placée sous le signe du partage
cette soirée aura su montrer toute la
richesse et la diversité de la culture
indienne une belle année 5119
[Musique]